welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and since the mcu
disappeared quicker than scarlet witch's
accent
a lot of us have been waiting with
baited breath for the arrival of one
division
it's finally out and hated i love it the
show has a lot of questions hanging over
it
what's going on with the weird sitcom
world who are the mysterious watchers
and what exactly is going on with the
townsfolk that seem to be trapped in
this weird reality
well throughout this video we're not
going to be answering those but we're
going to be discussing our thoughts and
theories on catherine hans character
who we now know is called agnes there's
a lot to go through but there will be
some spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to check
out the first two episodes then i highly
recommend that you check out now
we will be discussing some aspects of
the comics too in our theories
so this is a warning for your kids out
there yeah i don't hear nothing about
there being spoilers
now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns on the show every
week
and please click the thumbs up button if
you'd like vision down your throat
whilst you were choking too what anyway
without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the video okay so up top i did
cover some of these details in my
breakdown of episode one and two
so if you've already watched that and
want to skip ahead then have left time
codes below
however if you haven't seen it then as
mentioned earlier
agnes is a sort of nosy neighbor who
seems to know all the ins and outs of
the town
she's close with the mailman outlines
the way that the city works
and just seems to be too familiar with
wonder almost like she's keeping an eye
on her
although we don't know exactly who she
is the character has appeared in several
of the trailers
and in the first full-length one we saw
her revealing division that he was in
fact dead the character cackled about it
and clearly knew about the outside world
and though she could have easily been
awoken by the mind stone
her costume hinted at something else
ever since the first look at the trailer
dropped
i've always speculated that she's
actually agatha harkness
a super-powered witch that exists in the
marvel universe
a lot of people have said i don't know
that but actually
i'm the only one who knows and also the
other millions of people that said the
exact same thing now
hannah's kept pretty tight-lipped about
it but there are several clues that
point towards it being the case
now firstly is the witch costume which
duh
don't need to reach into your mind to
tell you the connection there
throughout the preview of the halloween
episode we did see that wonder and
vision were dressed up in their comic
book accurate costumes
and if this motif has anything to go by
then it's telling us
exactly who these people really are and
therefore it could be assumed that agnes
herself
is a witch the second clue is her name
itself
now if you take the first syllable of
agatha which gives you ag
and take the last syllable of harkness
which gives you ness
smush them together with a nice little
fading graphic and you have the name
agnes thirdly is the character's design
herself
and throughout not only all of the
posters but the episodes themselves
we've seen her wearing a brooch that is
very similar to the one that agatha duns
in the comics
now though this may be a bit of a reach
the item of clothing
clearly bears some importance as for
agatha herself
she dates back millennia and was a
witness to the fall of rome
atlantis and a lot more atlantis of
course plays a big part in the mcu
and the fact that the character is here
could actually usher in neymar at some
point
but that's a topic for another video now
agatha was first introduced as a nanny
that looked after reed and sue richard's
child
however she soon showed there was more
to her than meets the eye
and it wasn't too long before she
unveiled her incredible magical gifts
and abilities
we know that coming in episode 3 that
the pregnant wonder will likely give
birth to some children
and therefore if agnes becomes a
babysitter to them it ties back to her
original introduction in the comics
agatha is able to tap into the
universe's infinite store of ambient
magical energy
and similar to say the sorcerer's
supreme she can pull things across
into reality and manipulate them
throughout the year she's used these
gifts to form magical energy builds
create shields and a lot more agatha can
trick people with vast and expansive
illusions
and the character can also teleport
across the earth with ease
now agatha can do this through either
physical projection
or the astral plane and therefore
there's a lot going on beneath the
surface
because the character can tap into the
universe's infinite store of magic
similar to the sorcerer's supreme she
has remained ageless across the
millennia
i have no idea why she chose to stay in
the body of an old woman
but they could easily carry that across
to catherine han and just say that the
mcu's agatha tapped into her abilities
at a much younger age
now this age thing does cause some
issues well
well not really issues but originally in
the comics agatha's main weakness was
that because of her old age
she was pretty useless in hand-to-hand
situations
therefore them changing that here does
take away one of her biggest downfalls
and in my opinion it makes the character
a lot more threatening
now in the source material though she
relied heavily on magic
she was easy to tie her out but if she
is indeed much younger it could change
things up
however the agnes that we see could
indeed be a mask
and in the case of steve rogers we know
that the studio can convincingly age of
characters
so it could be revealed later down the
line that she's an old woman
masquerading as a young one now one of
the more interesting aspects about the
character
is that she did become somewhat of a
teacher to wonder and she's helped her
to develop her abilities
because the way one division throws you
in at the deep end we're still unsure
whether she went to agnes for help
or if she was taken taken by her i don't
know look
however going with the former theory
over the latter
wander could have explained the
situation with her losing vision
and agatha may have helped her to create
a pocket dimension
in which she was able to live out her
fantasies there really are a lot of
options
but it's clear that the agents of sword
believe that something has been done to
her
which is why they send radio messages
asking who it could be
now back to the babysitting thing and
this pregnancy came as a bigger shock
than i was to my dad
and it just came completely out of
nowhere this could indeed be tying into
the comics
as in them wonder has kids through
magical means
it seems all fine and dandy until agatha
reveals that the babies are in fact
carrying the souls of demons
and therefore they're not really the
kids that you want are they
if we look at how this ties into the
overall aesthetic of the show
then it could lend weight to the rumors
that mephisto aka the devil
will be revealed as being behind
everything though we don't know this for
definite yet
it has long been speculated that agnes
is working with the character
and this would not only tie into the
demon's souls which he will clearly want
to bring to earth
but there are other little details here
and there now shout outs to space
rogue and leonard pcoa on my last video
for pointing out that
dotty and agnes have a conversation in
which they talk about the following
the devil's in the detail which is what
he says and agnes replies with that's
not the only place he is
great impressions and this could be
hinting to the audience that he is
indeed
lurking in the background and the
villain could have sought out agnes in
order to have her go to wander under the
guise of a tutor
simply wishing to help her master her
abilities after showing her how to
create a pocket dimension
the pair then may have enacted a plan so
that they could get a pregnant in order
to bring the souls of the demons to life
because vision can move at super speed
whilst wonder possesses magical
abilities
these kids would be powerful allies to
have as part of mephisto's army
and that could be pointing to the larger
plot at play now for the moment these
are all of course thoughts and theories
but i do think there is enough reason
there to dive into them
obviously let me know what you think as
we've still got eight weeks ahead of us
in the show
and there's a lot to digest from it now
don't forget that on the 30th of january
we're giving away three copies of the
hobbit
and lord of the rings 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the theories the links to
our socials are in the description
and you can also support the channel by
clicking the join button and as a thank
you you get videos like this early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the first two episodes which will be
linked below
we go over all the easter eggs and
things you missed
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace